[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
interview mon invité ce soir Justine
Canales bonsoir vous êtes médecin
légiste l'Institut médicaux légal du CHU
de Tours et vous êtes à la tête de la
Maison des Femmes situées à l'hôpital
Bretonneau et spécialisé donc dans la
prise en charge des femmes victimes de
violence on va revenir avec vous sur vos
missions 18 mois maintenant donc cette
maison des femmes est ouverte et déjà
plus de 1000 consultations ça s'accélère
encore et encore qu'est-ce que ça
traduit selon vous cette traduit une
meilleure prise en charge des victimes
on se fasse mieux connaître raison de ma
présence aussi aujourd'hui et puis une
belle coordination entre chaque
partenaire et acteur du réseau
départemental et puis une volonté
globale d'amélioration la prise en
charge des victimes c'est dire s'il y
avait aussi un déficit en la matière
peut-être dans l'accompagnement des
femmes oui notamment dans le système de
soins et c'est pour ça qu'il était
nécessaire de créer un service
hospitalier de soins qui propose un
accompagnement global des femmes
victimes de violence et également de
leurs enfants
150 victimes prises en charge chaque
mois c'est ça aujourd'hui vous attendiez
à un tel chiffre non effectivement on
prenait déjà en charge des victimes de
violence à l'institut médico-légal aux
unités médicaux judiciaires et on
pensait déjà avoir beaucoup de patientes
qui avaient déposé plainte là on a
proposé justement cette possibilité
d'être prise en charge en dehors d'un
dépôt de plainte et on pensait
effectivement qu'on serait pas sur des
chiffres de cette ampleur alors l'âge
moyen des femmes qui viennent chez vous
et de 36 ans la plupart pour violence
intrafamiliale c'est-à-dire quelques
exemples de ces violences qui ne sont
pas que physique alors effectivement
donc ça peut être typiquement des
violences conjugales avec des violences
psychologiques des dévalorisations des
dénigrements des humiliations des
brimades au quotidien ça peut également
des violences physiques des violences
psychologiques pardon des violences
sexuelles économiques de tout ordre en
fait et à ce moment-là le franchissent
les portes elles se sentent rassurée
dans quel état arrive-t-elle justement
ces femmes chez vous alors ça peut être
des prises en charge en aiguë suite à
des violences qui viennent d'arriver
mais ça peut être également
dans les suites de violence plus
anciennes où il y a des conséquences
encore actuellement dans leur santé du
fait des violences ça dépend des
situations est-ce qu'elles ont toutes
quitté le foyer ou alors elles ont
encore cette crainte voilà de devoir y
retourner il y en a certaines
effectivement qui sont toujours au
domicile et parfois en danger donc c'est
important pour nous de l'évaluer pour
pouvoir les sécuriser alors vous êtes
ouvert 5 jours sur 7 avec une équipe
pluridisciplinaire quand une phase me
pousse la porte de la maison des femmes
comment était le prise en charge alors
dans un premier temps elle a
effectivement une première consultation
avec un médecin un médecin légiste et
une infirmière et on va prendre du temps
déjà prendre du temps pour parler des
violences de l'histoire de du parcours
des violences et puis de la vie de façon
générale d'abord la parole c'est ça et
puis permettre aussi d'identifier aux
femmes leur violence ce qu'elles ont
subi parce que souvent c'est difficile
pour elle parce que ça a été banalisé et
donc la première des choses c'est les
identifier pour pouvoir les déconstruire
et puis voir également quels sont les
conséquences que ça a pu entraîner dans
leur vie qu'elles soient psychologique
physique parce que des fois ça peut
entraîner des blessures mais également
social et donc l'objectif c'est de lever
l'ensemble de ces freins en proposant un
parcours et une prise en charge pour
qu'elle puisse retrouver leur autonomie
sortir de ces violences donc ça c'est
sur le moyen terme le long terme et dans
les situations d'urgence comment ça se
passe alors dans les situations
d'urgence évidemment l'objectif c'est
d'évaluer le besoin toujours notamment
quand il vient d'avoir eu lieu des
violences l'idée c'est de constater les
blessures proposer des soins quand c'est
nécessaire quand il y a des blessures
graves
et puis on peut également réaliser des
prélèvements médicaux légaux même quand
la patiente n'a pas déposé plainte comme
ça dans un deuxième temps si elle décide
si elle a la volonté de déposer plainte
elle pourra les utiliser et ça pourra
rentrer dans une procédure judiciaire
c'est une valeur pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de perte de chance même si elle n'a pas
déposé plainte parce qu'il faut aller
vite dans ces cas-là justement quand un
acte vient d'être commune violence vient
d'être commise oui effectivement
notamment dans le cadre des violences
physiques les Bleus peuvent disparaître
et c'est important de pouvoir les
constater et puis quand c'est des
violences sexuelle on a cinq jours pour
faire des prélèvements médico-légaux et
donc effectivement il faut aller vite
justement qu'elle dans la perspective
d'un éventuel procès vous l'avez évoqué
la preuve extrêmement importante quelle
est la marche à suivre en cas
d'agression de viol pour essayer autant
que possible de conserver ses preuves
l'idée c'est effectivement de consulter
rapidement un professionnel donc toutes
les portes d'entrée peuvent être belles
ça peut être en déposant plante mais
elle est aux urgences en discutant avec
un des professionnels beaucoup de
professionnels sur le département sont
formés et nous sollicitent pour qu'on
puisse intervenir rapidement et puis
expliquer justement la marche à suivre
en fonction des situations par exemple
le week-end vous ne pas ouvert là il
faut appeler le SAMU les urgences les
policiers qui fait toutes les personnes
qui font autorité toutes les personnes
qui travaillent la nuit les week-end
parce que effectivement beaucoup des
violences arrivent la nuit et les
week-ends
situation en fonction de des besoins
vous êtes un peu un thermomètre des
violences conjugales familiales quel est
votre ressenti est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que une parole se libère que
la prise en charge s'améliore ou
qu'elles augmentent ces violences alors
je peux pas dire qu'elles augmentent
j'en sais rien néanmoins effectivement
on a plus accès à ces femmes parce que
effectivement il y a une parle un peu
plus et puis on a aussi des
professionnels qui sont plus disponibles
pour accueillir ce type de parole donc
encore une fois je pense qu'il y a une
amélioration globale à tous les échelons
qui permet justement que ces femmes
puissent sortir du de ces violences et
vous les aider notamment quand les
franchissent votre porte à peut-être
trouver un logement ça c'est très
important aussi quand une femme est
victime de violence de pouvoir quitter
le foyer et le lieu du danger oui
effectivement après ça dépend aussi de
ces attentes et ses besoins mais quand
il y a cette volonté là et puis un
danger effectivement on puisse dans nos
ressources dans nos partenaires pour
mettre en place ce type de prise en
charge et puis un logement en urgence ça
c'est vous qui le faites pour l'instant
en tout cas oui pour pour l'instant
parce qu'effectivement on a vocation
avoir une assistante sociale et un
travailleur social en tout cas dans
notre structure ça c'est un poste à
financer encore parce que évidemment
notre structure est toute neuve et elle
a vocation à se développer parce que les
besoins sont intenses et pour cela on
recherche des cofinancement privés mais
également public parce qu'il faut un
fort engagement de l'État sur cette
enjeu de santé publique régionale de
santé qui vous finance pour l'instant
auteur de 220 000 euros
quand une mère quitte le foyer conjugale
elle le fait parfois avec son enfant
quel est votre rôle à ce moment-là alors
la première des choses c'est évidemment
de poser la question de savoir s'il y a
eu des violences directes sur les
enfants et puis souvent ce sont les
enfants qui sont covidim quoi qu'il
arrive qui ont été témoins ou qui ont
été à proximité des violences et donc
effectivement c'est de les orienter et
de dépister ces violences et
d'accompagner de façon générale la
famille pour qu'elle puisse se
reconstruire là aussi c'est votre
psychologue qui entre cette fois voilà
pour pour essayer de les faire parler
c'est pas facile de trouver les mots
auprès des enfants alors effectivement
l'idée c'est que nous on va pas
directement les enfants pour le moment
notre psychologue arrive en janvier aura
plutôt vocation à s'occuper des mamans
mais on a la chance d'avoir mis en place
un partenariat avec la CAF et si c'était
au petit enfant qui a permis de recruter
une éducatrice jeunes enfants qui permet
de s'occuper des enfants notamment
pendant le parcours des mamans et puis
d'accompagner aussi le lire la
parentalité et discuter autour de ces
éléments de violence vous alerter sur le
fait que ces violences intrafes
familiales surgissent pas du jour au
lendemain et parfois un phénomène
d'emprise qui va empêcher la victime
d'agir c'est-à-dire expliquez-nous un
petit peu donc le phénomène d'emprise
c'est quelque chose qui va se mettre en
place progressivement et qui va
instaurer une domination dans la
relation alors que normalement dans une
relation de couple classique il y a une
égalité une certaine égalité en tout cas
là il va y avoir une domination qui va
se mettre en place par différentes
étapes et puis une des premières enfin
une des étapes ça va être les violences
de différentes ordres psychologiques
avec des dénigrements des humiliations
comme on a dit tout à l'heure et puis ça
va se mettre de façon très insidieuse en
et par la suite la victime va devenir
dépendante parce qu'elle va se sentir
incapable c'est ce qu'on va lui répéter
un certain temps donc elle va finir par
le croire par exemple qu'est-ce qui peut
qu'est-ce qui revient régulièrement chez
ces femmes que vous rencontrez en fait
dans le cadre des violences souvent il y
a une phase dans le cycle des violences
qui
inverse la culpabilité c'est à dire que
l'auteur des violences va dire la
victime qu'elle est responsable de ce
qui se met en place
tu me rends dingues il s'excuses alors
pas toujours des astuces en tout cas une
justification et donc c'est victime vont
finir par le croire et penser qu'elles
sont responsables donc il va y avoir un
problème d'estime de soi et puis de
confiance en soi donc l'idée c'est que
ça va les empêcher de partir et puis des
fois les faire revenir parce que
effectivement il va y avoir un travail
une emprise sur les victimes qui les
rend vulnérables et plus fragiles une
alternance de violence est parfois aussi
de l'une de miel c'est ça aussi qui
revient et qui est très compliqué à
combattre pour une femme victime de
violence les phases de lune de miel ça
va être des phases un peu plus agréables
avec parfois même des très bons moments
c'est ce qui fait rentrer dans un
nouveau couple des violences et qui fait
en sorte que les cycles s'aggravent et
se perpétuent quel est le déclic chez
ces femmes comment elles décident
qui interviennent des fois ça peut être
les enfants qui sont présents et puis
des fois ça va être une fois de trop ça
dépend des situations ça peut être aussi
un professionnel de santé ou un
professionnel qui travaille auprès de la
patiente qui va lui dire que c'est pas
normal donc voilà c'est aussi verbalisé
et que chaque professionnel puisse
prendre sa place par rapport à ça
justement vous parliez des
professionnels il y a aussi les proches
comment
essayer de d'obtenir entre guillemets
des des aveux de la part de la victime
mais voilà vous voyez on soupçonne un
proche d'être une proche d'être victime
de violence comment on l'a fait parler
pour essayer de décanter une situation
l'idée c'est surtout que la confiance
parce que c'est des patientes et des
victimes qui n'ont plus confiance donc
effectivement faut rester sans jugement
et puis laisser libre cours à la parole
en fait
certaines femmes trouvent que la justice
les forces de l'or ne vont pas encore
assez vite ne sont pas assez
sensibilisés à la prise de plainte elles
ont d'ailleurs manifesté le week-end
dernier est-ce que c'est aussi votre
sentiment que trop d'affaires sont
encore
ignorés alors non effectivement je
j'entends cette ce discours et pour
autant on voit quand même une
amélioration dans notre quotidien les
prises de plainte qui sont de mieux en
mieux prises et puis des retours aussi
de la justice par rapport aux situations
donc on a la chance de voir une
amélioration donc ça c'est encourageant
on parle de l'avenir de cette maison des
femmes vous avez des projets de
développement où les avez brièvement
évoqués pour améliorer encore la prise
en charge ou est-ce que vous souhaitez
aller à moyen terme alors nous un moyen
terme on veut rester à l'hôpital parce
que ça a beaucoup de sens on est protégé
à l'hôpital donc ça c'est assez
intéressant et puis ça nous permet aussi
de travailler avec toute l'équipe
hospitalière et nos collègues au
quotidien sur certaines situations parce
que souvent il y a d'autres problèmes
notamment médicaux et donc l'idée c'est
vraiment qu'on reste à l'hôpital mais
qu'on construise une maison des femmes
pour pouvoir y accueillir toute notre
équipe
il va y avoir d'autres antennes et ce
qui pourrait y avoir des maisons des
femmes un petit peu partout notamment en
milieu rural effectivement l'idée c'est
que ce type de structure se développe
partout après on le souhaite évidemment
ce qui fait la force de la maison des
femmes c'est sa visibilité c'est ça vous
diriez aujourd'hui
effectivement et après c'est quelque
chose qui n'existait pas auparavant et
c'était un besoin
merci beaucoup Justine Canalès on
rappelle que la Maison des Femmes et si
tu as l’hôpital Bretonneau de boulevard
tonnlé un numéro le 02 47 47 46 00 merci
beaucoup encore d'être venu ce soir sur
notre plateau et c'est la fin de cette
interview merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
très bon weekend
[Musique]